2022 FIFA World Cup was built on slave
labor let me explain Qatar is a pretty
tiny country in the Middle East and it's
home to only about 330 000 native
qataris so when FIFA awarded Qatar the
right to host the 2022 World Cup the
government faced a massive problem if it
wanted to host a successful World Cup it
would have to build seven new stadiums
completely renovate one existing Stadium
construct more than a thousand
kilometers of New Roads build a
completely new Metro system and build an
entire new city to host hundreds of
thousands of fans being one of the
richest nations in the world the 300
billion dollar price tag for hosting the
World Cup wasn't the problem the problem
was finding the people finding the labor
to build it all see as a rich oil Nation
with a GDP per capita of sixty six
thousand dollars very few of those 330
000 native qataris were interested in
doing construction and even fewer were
interested in working Hospitality or
collecting garbage like a peasant so
what was the Qatar government to do hire
foreign workers obviously but not just
any 4 foreign workers poor desperate
workers from South Asia not only are
they dirt cheap but there are so many of
them that all the Qatar government had
to do was open the gates and the slaves
would come flooding in most of them saw
working in Qatar as an opportunity to
make more money than they ever could
back home koaka earned almost double
what I earned in Nepal that is why I
went End quotes So one Nepali worker
that migrated to Qatar here was Qatar
with the opportunity to lift hundreds of
thousands of migrants out of poverty
here was the government offering unfair
salary in housing and all they had to
deal was sign the dotted line but that
is where they were sadly mistaken by
latan the first World Cup match kicked
off Qatar was home to more than 2
million migrant workers but their lives
were no better than if they were to have
just stayed home in fact their lives got
much much worse see instead of paying
workers Fair salaries and treating them
like human beings the Qatari government
did the exact opposite they turned these
migrant workers into modern day slaves
slaves that lived in labor camps slaves
that were never paid on time or what
they were promised slaves that were
abused by their employers by the legal
system and yet the World Cup was silent
the fans were silent and the show went
on
and now that it's all over hundreds of
thousands of Migrant workers are
stranded in Qatar with no hope for the
future
this is what human rights Watchers call
modern day slavery in Qatar
[Music]
centuries ago Islamic countries created
something called the kafala system the
kaphala system was established as a way
to protect foreign workers who didn't
understand the country's laws or Customs
see under the kafala system every single
migrant worker that came to Qatar needed
a sponsor the sponsor could be a private
company that needs cheap labor for
example the sponsor would be responsible
for applying for visas making sure their
employees didn't break any of the
country's laws Etc and on the surface
the kafala system made sense Islamic
countries have very strict rules that
also applied to foreigners sponsors
understood all these nuances they knew
the language and could help guide
foreign workers with their Visa and
legal status but over the years it
morphed into something else completely
we covered the cafala system in depth
and how other Gulf countries abused
besides just Qatar in a lesson titled
that Asian slaves of Middle Eastern Oil
this is a lesson in our course Financial
slavery masterclass which I'll link to
below this course is basically these
videos on steroids about how the world
runs off of slavery and how you can
benefit link below but in the case of
Qatar see to get Qatari sponsor workers
would have to join a recruitment agency
and pay a recruitment fee often in the
thousands of dollars these poor South
Asian workers can't afford this that's
why they're trying to get a job so what
usually ends up happening is they end up
shackling themselves in debt to get
recruited
to work abroad first you have to pay
recruitment fees which are illegal but
routine in Nepal it can cost workers
fifteen hundred dollars to get a job in
Qatar this can mean going deeper into
debt before actually making any money he
borrowed money from a local lender that
charged him 36 percent interest
he hoped to earn enough money to pay it
back once the once the crew did they
would be matched with a business in
Qatar that needed their labor and that
is where things got messy once a migrant
worker arrived in Qatar nine times out
of ten their sponsor would confiscate
their passport why for a safe keeping
they said but in reality as a sponsor
confiscating their passports is a great
way to make sure they can never leave
think about it they don't know the
language they don't have any friends
there they can't go to a lore and Sue so
if you take away their passport their
ticket to freedom they're gonna be stuck
they're working for you for life
and from there things just got uglier if
they wanted their passport back they
would have to do whatever you forced
them to basically the workers became the
property of the sponsor don't do what I
say I'll get you deported back to your
country and won't pay you a cent
complaining about your hours or not
getting paid deported
but earlier this year the company Kumar
worked for abruptly stopped paying
thousands of workers
he and his fellow workers staged a rare
protest blocking the road
foreign
[Music]
says he and dozens of others spent more
than a week in jail and then police
escorted them to their labor camp Texas
the government paid some back wages and
sent them to their home countries
a country official told us that the
workers left voluntarily but Kumar says
they didn't have a choice but we don't
know what to do we don't have resonance
permits we are here illegally our
employer can run away at any time he is
not equatori National we are heading
into seven months without salary me
personally I am okay but what about my
kids now my eldest son is at home he can
now go to school end quotes said one
worker and then there were the living
conditions
[Music]
the living conditions these slaves I
mean my rent workers had to live in were
brutal
this is one of the camps from afar this
is what the entrance looks like this is
one of the bathrooms and this is one of
the hallways you would live in filled
with trash and rebel some housing
districts house over 800 000 of them
they were overcrowded have poor
ventilation poor health quote there are
not four people per room but sometimes
eight on bunk beds showers on kitchens
are in a state of despair let alone
ventilation noise it is a nightmare in
the summertime that's even worse 50
degrees and fires are not uncommon in
these camps that are not at all up to
safety standards when Kenyan worker says
End quotes and Katara alcohol is
strictly regulated so these migrant
workers end up having to buy illegal
homemade liquor as an escape quote a lot
of workers here get hooked on alcohol
and never fully recover in the summer
workers often die of heat stroke after
falling asleep outside drunk after an
evening at the field one guard tells the
independent End quotes and when foreign
journalists try to expose all this stuff
sometimes they get imprisoned well we
were on a quiet stretch of road in the
capital Doha on our way to film a group
of workers from Nepal suddenly eight
white cars have rented our vehicle and
directed us to a side road at speed a
dozen security officers frisked Us in
the street shouting at us when we tried
to talk they took away our equipment and
hard drives and drove us to the
headquarters at a 100 we were taken to a
local prison End quotes quote BBC
journalist Mark Lobos says he spent two
nights in prison and the BBC says his
equipment has not yet been returned a
Qatari government statement said the BBC
crew was detained because it trespassed
on private property End quotes
foreign
system allowed qatar's construction and
Hospitality businesses to solve the
labor problem in the most efficient way
possible and even after Qatar abolished
the system in 2020 after most of the
work was done anyways the migrant
workers were still being treated the
exact same way a migrant worker couldn't
make a single move in Qatar without
their sponsor's permission want to quit
and go home sorry I have your passport
and your contract doesn't end until two
years from now want to switch to a
different job where you can actually get
paid on time whoops you need my
permission to change shops and I'm not
giving it even workers who were
seriously ill were denied the right to
take sick leave or go home
foreign
times before he was allowed to return
home because the staffing agency who
hired him illegally held his passport
most of these workers ended up earning
much less than they were promised others
weren't paid at all and in some cases
some workers were forced to stay in
their labor camp for weeks without any
food until the police came and told them
their employers had been arrested more
than 6 500 migrant workers died in the
12 years I took Qatar to prepare for the
World Cup airport officials say three to
four bodies arrive here on average each
day
mostly from the Gulf and Malaysia sure
some of them probably died of natural
causes but the majority were young fit
men who had all passed Health tests
before coming to work they were men in
the prime of their life but according to
the Qatari government they just dropped
dead and for those who were lucky enough
to survive the Heat malnourishment and
dangerous working conditions to see the
World Cup come to a close things aren't
much better than they were before
[Music]
foreign
what the World Cup officially over most
migrant workers and Qatar are still in
depth recruitment fees living costs and
not being paid their salaries on time
has made it impossible for most of them
to use the little money they made to
actually pay off their debts most
migrant workers and Qatar made just
around 200 a month and after taking out
thousands of dollars in loans just to
get to Qatar they're no better off to
date than they were 12 years ago now
with no more big construction jobs
available these migrant workers have
just three options one stay in Qatar and
hope they find another low-paying job to
replace the one they just lost after the
World Cup ended and face the risk of
being deported for no reason as you go
about your day
two they can willingly go home if their
employers allow them or three they can
take on more debt to find more work in
some other Gulf country
those who left Qatar told us they're
trying to go abroad again
[Music]
the workers who are still there say they
need to stay
it's clear it's hard needed cheap labor
to build itself up for the World Cup and
now that it's over the government is
purging the country of all these
peasants that made it possible imagine
telling your family about all the riches
you're gonna make in the Gulf leaving
them behind for 12 years only to find
yourself in debt your passport
confiscated working every day getting
sick exhausted fearing for your life
only to find yourself in the same
position you were in before except now
over a decade has passed you're forever
in debt your kids have grown up and they
never got to spend any time with you
that is the reality of most of qatar's
Migrant workers today despite the risks
and the sacrifices most of the workers
who spoke to us say they felt forced to
continue trapped between poverty and
death and the difficult or dangerous
jobs they just can't afford to lose
[Music]
Qatar spent on the same 220 billion
dollars on the World Cup that's at least
40 billion dollars more than qatar's
entire GDP in 2021. 220 billion dollars
to make the World Cup a success and that
was with slave labor but think about how
much more it would have cost if Qatar
wasn't able to use slave labor if they
actually had to pay Fair salaries to the
migrant workers it just would have not
been feasible qatar's World Cup would
have never been possible without slave
labor and the scariest thing is that
it's not just Qatar all the biggest
governments of the world all the biggest
corporations they've all gone to where
they're at because of one thing slavery
but not traditional slavery were whips
and chains but with financial slavery
like what Qatar did and if you want to
reach the same Heights of money and
power this is something you're gonna
have to learn and be aware of yourself
the problem is this has always been kept
a closely guarded secret for obvious
reasons but not anymore because once I
realized all this after years of
researching and making these videos I
knew I had to expose it all so I
compiled all my research into something
thing called Financial slavery
masterclass more than 20 plus lessons
all narrated by me in the same
documentary style format you've come to
love and this master class is all
centered around this fundamental secret
of modern day slavery and how you can
use it to gain more wealth and power for
yourself I've spent the last six months
crafting this masterclass and dare I say
it is a masterpiece just scroll down
click the link below and watch the first
lesson for free right now plus by buying
this you'll also have the chance to earn
around 100 for every person you refer to
the master class and just like Andrew
Tate's affiliate program we give you
step-by-step instructions on how to turn
clips of our videos into viral tick
tocks and YouTube shorts so you can get
more sales tape paid his Affiliates 25
per sign up and some of them were making
over eleven thousand dollars a week but
we're gonna pay you four times that
amount at around a hundred dollars for
every sale you get so scroll down click
the link below and buy now
foreign
[Music]